The decentralized and unregulated part
of blockchain is a key aspect but it has
to coincide with
what is actually people's reality and
company's reality and that they live in
a regulated space and um for example me
for me as a Swede I've had long
discussions with my bank where I was
actually getting paid in crypto and uh
was trying to get them to accept it and
after about a year of negotiating they
did accept it but basically say saying
don't do anything fancier than that is
that is as long as you just get paid in
crypto we can accept it start trading in
crypto or trying to run a business on
crypto we'll kick you out because we
don't know what the rules are the
finance inspection doesn't know what the
rules are scared to death of being
caught up in mon money laundering
accusations ations. We won't touch you
with a 10-ft pole. And and of course, I
had some cute ideas about things that I
could possibly evolve as a business, but
I knew full well that I couldn't do it
in Sweden. Uh because the regulation
simply isn't there. And uh it's not just
that the regulators are stupid, they
definitely are not. H it's not that they
don't understand blockchain. they're
they're actually tracking the space
pretty closely. Um but the solutions are
not there to yet to tie it together so
that you can get the benefits of
blockchain, the decentralization, the
unregulated
uh core where we actually need that.
and and then regulated pockets that are
adapted to what you actually have to
submit to to in order to do business in
your coffee shop or trading facility.
>> Absolutely right. And you know when we
talked about RIPER, Ripper is a quite a
simplistic uh acronym to place to
understanding both a technological stack
and a commercial
what that means from a commercial
perspective. Um so when we talk about
the gajimaru as a resource layer what
we're saying is the resource layer is
the mint the the proof of work
untamperable
core and then you can leverage on top of
that associate chains that use proof of
stake proof of authority and allow
people to do things exactly like you've
talked about and begin to make that
transition from resource to
infrastructure where for example Swedish
banks the Swedish regulator and the
Swedish Central Bank get together and
say, "Okay, so we'll have a proofofstake
blockchain operated by all of the
regulated players in this space for the
purposes of providing platforms and
applications to the Swedish people to
engage in financial service operations.
It